[Music]  pregnant Serena Williams's fiance Alexis  Ohanian gushes over the kind of mother  she will be she's very good at a lot of  things and and well on her way to being  an awesome mom to the 34 year old reddit  co-founder was a guest on CNBC's Squawk  Box on Friday where he couldn't seem to  contain his excitement over becoming a  first-time father revealing he'll even  be taking time off from his reddit  duties to spend time with his budding  family I'll be taking off for six weeks  myself that's great and trying to do my  best the best job possible as a new  daddy Serena and Alexis will welcome  their first child together later this  year the 35 year old Olympian first  revealed the couple was expecting in  April when she posted this sweet mama to  be selfie on accident to snapchat  [Music]  you